le nouvel opus de la franchise mormone
est un film coup de poing ce qui ne
laissera personne indifférent
c'est très simple dames ça fait un an
qu'elle attend le réalisateur
montréalais henri pardo a vu panthère
noire lors d'une première médiatique
il y voit plus qu'un simple film de
divertissement se dit aussi à nos
enfants est ce qu'on est ce qu'on est ce
qu'on reste dans ce présent là qui nous
après soit on se donne la liberté de se
projeter dans ce futur là où on y
contrôle de nos destinées terrenoir est
l'histoire d'un royaume en afrique
akli wakanda ses habitants vivent coupés
du reste du monde grâce ou vibranium un
métal qui leur a permis de construire
une cité prospère et très avancés
technologiquement du ciel mais rien ne
va plus lorsque deux hommes s'affrontent
pour le titre de panthère noire
ici presque toute la distribution met en
scène des personnes noires qui prennent
en main leur destinée
quel genre car on a tu souhaitais venir
dans le monde de wakanda sur les femmes
sont égales aux hommes et sans elle le
royaume en souffrirait moi je regardais
cette nuit là j'ai l'impression d'être à
la maison avec mes tantes ma mère mes
cuisines qui sont égales et puis qui
m'aide à aller plus loin une reste pas
figée la réussite de ce film est dans sa
proposition audacieuse qui nous fait
sortir des sentiers battus contre la
mythologie africaine et une vision
optimiste du futur en terre noire est en
partie une affirmation de la fierté
d'être une personne noire
rien à voir avec une foule
majoritairement noirs ça va se passer
il ya déjà des groupes qui s'organisent
pour le voir qu'ils ont loué des salles
qui vont prendre la parole tu es un
homme bon ici louis fait depuis mai
radu qu'un de montréal